entführt begrüße ich jetzt professor
peter dabrock theologe und acht jahre im
deutschen ethikrat zunächst 2012 bis
2016 als stellvertretender vorsitzender
dann von 2016 bis 2020 als vorsitzender
herr dabrock impfpflicht für
pflegekräfte würde doch viele probleme
auf einmal lösen
guten morgen herr ramsauer erst mal ja
ich glaube das ist eine
gespensterdebatte
das sind die falschen leute die
angesprochen sind falsche reihenfolge
das das falsche mittel und ist der
falsche zeitpunkt also zu all diesen
vier aspekten kann man jeweils
rückfragen stellen an markus söder die
debatte losgetreten hat das hilft gerade
niemanden und am wenigsten denjenigen
die sich so engagiert im kampf gegen
korona einsetzen und dabei doch so
schlecht bezahlt werden die menschen in
der pflege aber wenn nun tatsächlich
sich abzeichnet in einigen wochen oder
vielleicht ein zwei monaten dass die
bereitschaft zur impfung gerade in
dieser gruppe der pflegekräfte so gering
ist wo ist für sie der zeitpunkt wo man
sagt jetzt müssen wir nachsteuern
ja also man kann natürlich viele
debatten führe man kann auch viele
überlegungen haben aber die sollten
zielführend sein und da muss man ab
schichten und das scheint mir bei der
stellungnahme von herrn söder so nicht
passiert zu sein
fangen wir damit an dass die
masernimpfung die nimmt er als vergleich
anders einzuschätzen ist als die impfung
hier gegen korona bei der korona impfung
erstens brauchen wir 60 bis 70 prozent
der bevölkerung um eine herdenimmunität
zu erreichen das ist bei der masern
impfung deutlich höher und dann ganz
gewichtiger punkt wir wissen überhaupt
noch nicht ob die impfung gegen co wird
tatsächlich auch die übertragbarkeit
hindert hindert oder nur den verlauf der
krankheit
auch das ist noch mal ein großer
unterschied
und ich glaube dann ist es auch nicht
richtig
die gruppe jetzt in den blick zu nehmen
zu denen wir derzeit noch immer
keine verlässlichen zahlen haben und
bevor man dann über impfpflicht redet
sollte man dann erst mal darüber
nachdenken dass man aufklärungen
voranbringt dass man das gespräch auf
augenhöhe mit respekt mit diesen
menschen führt das sind alles mit ihm
zunächst erst mal in den blick nehmen
sollte bevor man eine gruppe so
stigmatisiert die sich dann auch noch so
für die kranken einsetzt und weithin wir
wissen da brauchen wir jeden einzelnen
das ist keine form von respekt man
sollte nicht drohen man sollte werben
jetzt warten wir mal unseren blick wir
waren eben bei den pflegekräften jetzt
gehen wir mal auf die gesamtbevölkerung
da gibt es ja eine sogenannte
priorisierung dh wer wird als erstes
geimpft wird als nächstes geimpft
da gibt es mehrere gruppen aber das hat
ja auch jens spahn der
gesundheitsminister jahr vorgetragen die
spannende frage ist doch jetzt bei
dieser priorisierung das ist eine
verordnung nun gibt es ja die
berechtigte frage hätte das nicht in ein
gesetz gegossen werden sollen
ja das ist eine ganz wichtige fragen die
sie stellen ich bin selber heute
nachmittag bei einer anhörung allerdings
virtuell zugeschaltet im deutschen
bundestag muss genau um diese fragen
geht um meine position ist er ganz klar
bei solchen fragen die eine solche
grundrechts und gesellschaftsrelevante
haben gilt der parlamentsvorbehalt das
gehört in den kernbereich dessen was das
parlament zu bearbeiten hat das sind
nicht nur medizinische fakten dort geht
es um normative festlegen
das muss im parlament besprochen werden
und ich halte es für ein großes
demokratiedefizit dass das nicht
passiert ist und das gefährdet ein
weiteres mal das so notwendige vertrauen
in die pandemie bekämpfung und es wäre
genug zeit gewesen das zu machen und ich
hoffe dass bei auch material noch
anstehenden verbesserungen die
bundesregierung und die die
bundesregierung tragenden parteien im
bundestag das einsehen dass sie hier
nachbessern müssen das ist eine frage
unserer demokratischen kultur das ist
jetzt auch für einige formale fragen ob
das eine verordnung oder eingesetzt
werden sollen jetzt möchte ich mal sie
ganz konkret nach der priorisierung
fragen
und bei der priorisierung ist es ja so
dass zunächst alte menschen geimpft
werden und auch daneben wenn sie denn
wollen das pflegepersonal nur dann sagen
aber viele wissenschaftler im mutationen
die uns ja möglicherweise noch viel
gefährlicher werden entstehen bei den
jungen menschen glauben sie dass diese
priorisierung wirklich so sinnvoll ist
und auch vertretbar
sehen sie dass es genau einer der punkte
die man im parlament mit gesprächen muss
und deswegen ist die frage wie man das
parlament einbindet natürlich nicht nur
eine formale frage sondern da geht es
wirklich um den wesens kern unseres
demokratischen zusammenlebens ich selber
würde tatsächlich sagen wenn ich mir die
priorisierung reihenfolge anschaue dann
ist das moment unter sprechen sie gerade
auch an der exponiertheit noch gar nicht
hinreichend mit berücksichtigt also ein
system relevanter ministerialdirektor
der aber zu hause im home office setzt
der muss erstens nicht prioritär
gegenüber einer verkäufern oder einem
verkäufer an der kasse geimpft werden
die oder der dann den ganzen tag nur
durch eine plastikscheibe getrennt ganz
ganz vielen menschen gegenüber sitzt und
so ähnlich ist es eben auch in der
schule auch dort ist quasi und wir sind
ja auch bald mal wieder über
präsenzunterricht nachdenken die gefahr
gegeben dass man fremden vielen menschen
begegnet und das muss einfach viel
stärker debattiert werden und da kann
man auch nicht nur sagen da zählt eine
virologische richtung da müssen dann
auch epidemiologen
gesundheitswissenschaftler gehört werden
müssen dann auch soziologen über
verhaltensweisen gehört werden und das
vor dem hintergrund der
unterschiedlichen einstellungen die in
der gesellschaft vorhanden sind und das
wird in der regel dann alles gebündelt
im parlament und da gehört es dann auch
hin
das sagt peter dabrock theologe und
ehemaliger vorsitzender des deutschen
ethikrates herzlichen dank für das
gespräch nach führt gerne